roe v wade this is actually a pretty
good one for
dave rubin roe v wade should be
overturned
i've spent my life trying to avoid this
question yes
now you know that now that's saying okay
that question is actually leaves open a
few different interpretive possibilities
but i mean you know my answer but right
so okay so your answer obviously is this
yes what do you think my answer is that
roe v was at the court case
that took this issue away from the
states it's certainly the dominant
reading of it should be overturned
i'm gonna out you i think right now i
don't know if you've talked about this
publicly
you haven't told me any of this
privately
i think you believe that roe v wade
should be overturned even if you
don't agree with all pro-life laws or
i think on the court case you would
agree michael as you know i made a
begrudging
pro-choice 12-week argument in don't
burn this book new york times
best-selling don't burn this book great
book by the way great book
um that being said and i think
maybe i've discussed this once on some
random podcast because someone flat out
asked me
the defense of the idea that it should
be a federal law
doesn't really make any sense to me and
of course you should kick it back to the
states and the states should decide
and really if if liberals could stand on
any principle that would make sense
well then if the idea is okay well now
these 12 let's say southern ish states
are going to ban abortion if you really
want abortion access well then you can
still do non-profits to get people
to cross state lines and all that i know
you wouldn't be thrilled with that and i
don't
i don't love the idea i'm not sitting
here like i love abortion but you're
just talking about i'm just talking
about like court be doing
and what and what freedom is and
federalism and everything else
so you were quite astute on that one
cheers to that you were
you were quite right well because
there's a difference between your own
personal beliefs and personal morality
and what the legal system
you know the constitution sets up yeah
oh fabulous this is great good one
whoever put that question
that is a good that is a good one i
don't you pay these people out of your
pocket right now i don't ever put that
question in
yeah and by the way um
[Music]
you